eckert puisque vous entendez c'est assez
régulièrement des moments de tension un
petit peu derrière moi alors ça fait
suite à une mobilisation qui a duré
plusieurs heures sur cette place de la
république on rappelle qu initialement
cette manifestation devait se diriger
vers la place de l'opéra et finalement
donc elle est restée statique les
jaunards monte empêché le cortège
d'avancé alors que vouloir donner
attention reprend un petit peu avec un
mouvement de foule qui démarre voilà en
tout cas
mais manifestation est donc resté sur
cette place de la république cet après
midi avec beaucoup de manifestants issus
de plusieurs horizons différents avaient
beaucoup le gilet jaune aussi je propose
d'écouter vos romans driguet ce qu'on a
intérêt d'être à l'heure aujourd'hui on
nous interdit de manifester la policière
s'est pris la liberté qui est la sienne
aujourd'hui en tant que citoyen français
de pouvoir manifester sur les
champs-elysées et nous on nous empêche
de prendre le chemin de la manifestation
mais ça va paraître fou mais ils ont
droit la france est un pays démocratique
je cautionne pas le message leur message
c'est de la merde de pouvoir manifester
pour avoir le droit d'être anglais pour
avoir le droit de mutilés y a pas pire
message mais on vit dans un pays qu'est
la démocratie
à eux de parler à eux de s'expliquer à
nous de les contredire
mais pourquoi nous aujourd'hui on n'a
pas le droit de manifester pourquoi moi
aujourd'hui j'ai perdu année parce que
j'ai pris ce droit de manifester la
justice ne donnera pas raison il n'y
aura pas de justice
comme pour tous les gilet jaune mutilés
voilà et pendant que vous écoutiez
jérôme andries détention ont repris vous
le voyez au loin sur ces images on image
de lacrymogènes les forces de l'ordre
ont donc à nouveau utilisé des
lacrymogènes dans une foule une foule un
peu moins nombreuses que tout à l'heure
il y avait plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de personnes là il ya un peu de
monde qui est déjà parti sur cette place
de la république mais encore des
personnes présentes pour faire entendre
leurs revendications et dans une
ambiance un peu plus tendue que tout à
l'heure effectivement et thomas on l'a
on le sait cette manifestation n'avait
pas été autorisée pour raison de crise
sanitaire les rassemblements de plus de
dix personnes sont théoriquement
interdite mais cette manifestation a été
tolérée par la préfecture de police de
paris à condition qu'elle reste statique
est elle toujours statique 7 cette
manifestation autour de vous et comment
est-ce qu'on commençait ses tensions on
aperçoit des des jeunes qui portent des
masques évidemment à cause de la crise
sanitaire mais quelques jeunes aussi
cagoulés habillés en noir thomas
en fait les forces de l'ordre sont
disposés sur toutes les entrées et les
sorties de cette place ça veut dire
qu'ils empêchent ils ont empêché en tout
cas une pendant une bonne partie de
l'après midi les manifestants d'avancer
de sortir de cette place de la
république alors maintenant il ya rue du
faubourg-du-temple les gendarmes
laissent passer ceux qui veulent quitter
la manifestation mais en tout cas
effectivement cette manifesation n'a pas
pu démarrer lorsque le cortège s'est
élancé il avait notamment les
organisateurs notamment à sa traoré qui
était en tête de ce cortège elle a
essayé de discuter avec les forces de
l'ordre mais a priori cela n'a pas
fonctionné puisque les gendarmes en
l'occurrence ne les ont pas laissés
progresser initialement il avait prévu
un autre tracé pour cette manifestation
ils ont finalement annoncé dans le
mégaphone en tout cas un des
organisateurs a annoncé que cette
manifestation serait statique il a
appelé les personnes présentes à rester
le plus longtemps possible sur cette
place pour faire entendre les
revendications et finalement c'est
depuis donc cette place de la république
que les slogans ont été scandés pendant
que pendant une bonne partie de
l'après-midi faut le dire il n'y avait
pas vraiment de tensions pendant cette
manifestation quelques points petit peu
chaud notamment lorsque cette banderole
a été déployée par génération
identitaire mais jusque là les choses se
déroulaient plutôt correctement dans
l'ensemble est effectivement depuis
quelques minutes maintenant
il ya des tensions avec des manifestants
qui sont en fait à proximité des forces
de l'ordre a eu des jets de projectiles
de leur part les forces de l'ordre ont
répliqué les ambiances évidemment est en
train de se tendre à mesure que la
manifestation se poursuit et les
commerçants aux alentours de 7 places de
la république et aux abords de ce
quartier du 11e arrondissement ont été
priés de baisser le rideau thomas on le
sait des commerçants qui ont déjà été
durement impactée par la crise sanitaire
notamment les restaurateurs et les cafés
que voyez-vous autour de vous
alors on arrivant sur cette place de la
république effectivement on a vu des
commerçants fermaient boutique des
restaurateurs notamment
il faut dire que cette place de la
république est une place assez courante
pour les manifestations donc qui avait
pas vraiment de surprise de leur part
même si évidemment le contexte sanitaire
fait que cette fermeture peut être bien
plus préjudiciable qu'à l'accoutumée en
tout cas ces restaurateurs ont fait
enfermer boutique est évidemment toutes
les boutiques autour de cette place de
la république sont closes vous pouvez
l'imaginer pas de dégradation a dénoté
en revanche je n'ai pas pu constater de
dégradations sur d'éventuelles magasin
ou d'éventuels détriment des distances
sociales qui ne sont pas vraiment
respecté non plus
oui alors il faut il faut préciser que
va dire 90 % des gens ici porte un
masque
malgré tout évidemment les forces de
sécurité et des services sanitaires ne
peuvent pas être respectés vu le nombre
de personnes qui sont là je vous le
rappelle beaucoup le monde plusieurs
milliers de personnes pour cette place
de la république alors évidemment les
gestes barrières sont un peu compliqué à
mettre en place c'est en revanche
beaucoup de personnes portent un masque
et on a vu notamment beaucoup de gens
également s'est lavé les mains assez
régulièrement avec l'intérêt que cela
peut apporter en tout cas on voit alors
au moment où je vous parle vous allez
voir sur ces images l'intervention de la
brave qui est en train de se déployer
sur sur la place de la république pour
dire que les tensions sont en train de
reprendre puisque derrière moi il ya des
lacrymogènes et on voit des policiers de
la brave qui sont en train d'intervenir
je sais pas si vous pouvez les
apercevoir ils sont en train
d'intervenir sur la place de la
république ils sont les policiers de la
brave disposés derrière les barrages
policiers et les gendarmes qui sont
déployés comme je vous le disais sur les
différentes artères autour de cette
place est là visiblement ils vont
procéder à une interpellation est un peu
loin je vous cache pas pour bien suivre
ce qui se passe mais en tout cas ils
vont certainement procéder à une
interpellation et sa rameute un peu de
gens autour de lui de ses de la brave
pardon pour et bien assisté à ce qu'il
va se passer
effectivement on le voit sur ces images
en direct thomas vous nous parliez de
ces policiers qui interviennent
régulièrement dans la dans la foule pour
tenter de l'interpeller des personnes
responsables qui auraient été
responsables notamment de deux jets de
projectiles ou autres comportements
contre les policiers
des policiers qui sont restés depuis le
début de l'après-midi en tout cas assez
stoïque face à cette manifestation qui
n'avaient pas été autorisées au
préalable
place de la république donc
régulièrement les manifestants on l'a vu
cours en direction des forces de l'ordre
qui aussitôt interviennent pour tenter
de 2
de les circonscrire sur cette place de
la république et faire en sorte que
cette manifestation ne déborde pas dans
les rues alentour une manifestation à
l'initiative du comité adama traoré la
demi-soeur d'ailleurs de la victime a
pris la parole en début d'après midi
place de la république
elle a critiqué notamment la
mobilisation des policiers français hier
qui sont accusés de racisme et qui se
sont senti lâché par le ministre de
l'intérieur écoutez la cette machine de
guerre qui en face de nous cette machine
de guerre qui n'a ni sentiment ni états
d'âme venir aux morts où tous les coups
sont permis
où tous les coups sont plus puissants ou
c'est une broyeuse qui se met en place à
nous mais devant on reversera cette
machine de guerre pour récupérer une
bonne france cette france qui lui
permettra de vivre dans l'unité cette
phrase qui nous permettra de vivre
ensemble cette phrase qui nous permettra
de vivre dans la tranquillité sanctuaire
ans policière hier nous avons des
policiers qui ont été manifestées pour
réclamer que la clé d'étranglement ne
soit pas interdite
d'accord il y fait du mal j'aimais pas
être en colère j'ai eu honte j'ai honte
de cette police française la clé
d'étranglement interdite la clé
d'étranglement qui a été interdite qui
va l'être en tout cas c'est ce qu'a
confirmé le ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner qui a écrit une
lettre hier soir aux policiers suite aux
entretiens qu'il a eus avec les
différents syndicats qui se sont succédé
hier suite à ces manifestations
policières plutôt exaspérés d'être taxé
de raciste dans leur globalité en tout
cas christophe castaner qui a donc
confirmé que la clé d'étranglement cette
clé qui est à l'origine de a priori de
l'étouffement de damas traoré je
rappelle qu'il ya quand même une dizaine
d' enquêtes qui ont été menées
concernant les origines de sa mort la
famille qui réclament justice donc et la
fin de cette clé d'étranglement qui a
qui a causé peut-être l'étouffement de
du frère dit ça est traoré place de la
république on le voit des manifestants
qui sont toujours présents avec moins de
monde
en tout cas qu'auparavant il est 17h55
c'est à peu près l'heure à laquelle en
général la dispersion se fait sentir
place de la république un peu moins de
monde mais toujours quelques tensions on
le voit avec ces jeunes pour la plupart
des beaucoup de jeunes sont venus pour
cette manifestation contre le racisme et
contre les violences policières
à l'initiative du comité adama traoré
et on le voit place de la république
toujours ce face à face entre ces jeunes
qui scandent des slogans contre les
policiers beaucoup de monde pour cette
manifestation qui n'avait pourtant pas
été autorisée pas non plus déclaré par
par les organisateurs
justice voilà ce que scandent les
manifestants des politiques étaient
présents aussi lors de ce rassemblement
en mémoire d'adama traoré
et qui c'est qui c'est déroulé donc ce
samedi pour la deuxième fois il y avait
jean luc mélenchon qui était présent sur
cette place et il a exprimé elle s'est
exprimée lui aussi sur le rôle des
forces de l'ordre en france
il souhaite également un changement
écoutez le il faut premièrement que la
police change les comportements que la
hiérarchie assume sa responsabilité et
il faut aussi que les le commun puisse
se reconnaître dans la police et pour ça
il faut qu'elle ait changé son
comportement voilà donc notre notre
présence c'est un geste d'union de paix
de rassemblement du peuple français
parce que c'est ça qui est en jeu si on
laisse instiller l'idée que à raison de
leur couleur de peau ou de leur religion
certains peuvent être traités d'une
manière indigne
alors ce n'est plus la france le rôle du
policier c'est d'être gardien de la paix
ils sont dix fois trop armés leur seul
accoutrement est une incitation gros
choc frontal et ça ce n'est pas vous
regardez les policiers à l'intérieur de
londres n'ont pas une arme et du coup
chacun comprend que c'est la dernière
des lâchetés de s'attaquer à un homme
désarmé ou à une femme d armée police et
aux policières qui est là pour faire
respecter le vivre ensemble il faut
avoir une société qui apaise plutôt
qu'elle ne fait montée en tension et on
va faire le point
place de la république on va rejoindre
notre reporter est el farj qui suit la
situation sur place
estelle si vous n'entendez qu'elle est
quelle est l'ambiance autour de vous
vous êtes dans une des rues
adjacentes en tout cas à cette place de
la république où il ya quelques tensions
actuellement alors je me trouve à
précisément à l'angle de la rue du
faubourg du temps et de la place de la
république juste à côté d'un point de
sortie vous allez pouvoir le voir sur
ces images de julien de la course et pas
ce point que les manifestants sont
censés quitter à cette place de la
république un des manifestants à qui je
vous le rappelle ont répondu à l'appel
du collectif
adama traoré qui sont venus à dénoncer
le racisme et les violences policières
au sein des forces de l'ordre à
concernant le cortège et bien il était
censé rejoindre la place de l'opéra mais
la préfecture de police a finalement
décidé que le rassemblement resterait et
statique la préfecture de police qui a
appelé les manifestants à se disperser
en raison des tensions à qui on est
émergé sur la place alors tout le moment
là où je me trouve l'ambiance et
et plutôt calme
voilà voilà ce que je peux vous dire
mais gagner au moment où je vous parle
et on entend effectivement quelques
grenades de désencerclement qui gronde
autour de vous et stèles seller donc
l'ordre de dispersion a donc été donnée
merci pour ces précisions on vous
retrouve évidemment pour suivre
l'évolution de cette situation place de
la république
des grenades de désencerclement qui sont
en train d'être retirée on le voit sur
ces images en direct place de la
république pour disperser les
manifestants est récalcitrant l'ordre a
donc été donné pour disperser cette
place beaucoup de monde pour cette
manifestation en tout cas pas la place
de la république était noire de monde
près de 5000 personnes selon les
chiffres du ministère de l'intérieur et
on l'entend toujours ces manifestants
qui scandent des slogans contre les ce
qu'ils appellent les violences
policières contre le racisme
ces manifestants qui ont décidé donc de
rester encore pour revendiquer leur
mécontentement face à ce qui s'est passé
en 2016 contre adama traoré adama traoré
qui est mort par essoufflement suite à
son interpellation alors qu'il était en
délit de fuite
beaucoup font d'ailleurs le parallèle
entre lui et georges floyd qui est mort
il y a quelques jours aux états unis
suite à son interpellation par des
policiers américains
cette personne est mort étouffé je ne
peux plus respirer c'est ce qu'avait dit
aussi adama traoré d'ailleurs sa soeur
issa traoré
elle a rappelé dans son discours elle
l'a répété cette phrase je ne peux plus
respirer pour dénoncer ces techniques
policières qui serais tu
à l'origine en tout cas selon l'enquêté
menée par par la famille les expertises
qui ont été menées par la famille qui
serait à l'origine de la mort de adama
traoré
des rassemblements donc qui se
poursuivent on le voit on va peut-être
faire un point avec notre reporter
thomas bonnet qui se trouvent de l'autre
côté de la place de la république
[Musique]
mais il faut qu'il soit prêt
moi je peux pas rester
alors effectivement la situation qui
évolue encore avec un mouvement de foule
à l'instant magali où les policiers ont
certainement charger à nouveau il ya en
fait un face à face qui est dure
maintenant depuis de longues minutes
entre les manifestants en tout cas un
groupe de manifestants très déterminés
particulièrement déterminé qui est ici
face à eux il ya les forces de l'ordre
et vous l'entendez des grenades de
désencerclement sont régulièrement
utilisé des lacrymogènes qui sont
viennent à nouveau d'être tirées par les
forces de l'ordre
situation qui dure depuis maintenant de
longues minutes avec d'un côté des
projectiles lancés par les manifestants
de l'autre les gendarmes me voyais la
situation qui s'envenime vraiment
puisque dès que les forces de l'ordre
chargent en fait elles sont elles
permettent d'ouvrir cette foule entre
guillemets et puis derrière la foule et
ces deux processus qui dure maintenant
depuis plusieurs minutes vous dire que
les manifestants qui sont ici tous à ces
jeunes finalement sont particulièrement
déterminés et la tension est en train de
monter d'un cran à furent au fur et à
mesure que cette manifestation se
poursuit puisque évidemment ce n'était
pas du tout le l'état d'esprit il y
encore quelques instants il faut dire
que cette manifestation statique
peut-être qu'elle a entraîné quelques
ressentiments quelques tensions chez
certains individus cher certaines
personnes qui n'hésitent pas désormais à
aller au contact avec les forces de
l'ordre et maintenant ça dure depuis
depuis un moment avec des slogans qui
sont scandés à nouveau et des
lacrymogènes qui sont tirées de plus en
plus fréquemment désormais par les
forces de l'ordre
on a vu tout à l'heure l'intervention de
la brave la brave qui est également
encore présentes et les forces de l'anp
ce que je peux dire c'est que les forces
de l'ordre qui sont mobilisés sur toutes
les rues de cette place de la république
sont aux abois il porte un casque et ils
sont prêts à intervenir puisque la
situation est désormais relativement
tendue à cet endroit là on est au
croisement avec la rue de turbigo c'est
l'endroit pour l'instant où vraiment la
situation est très tendue dans le reste
de la place de la république il ya moins
de manifestants tout à l'heure donc les
choses se calment un petit peu ce que
vous expliquez estelle mais à cet
endroit là il ya encore plusieurs
milliers de personnes et les choses sont
en train de devenir assez tendue merci
thomas pour toutes ces précisions on le
voit effectivement des jeunes qui
visiblement font face aux forces de
l'ordre qui n'ont pas l'intention en
tout cas de 2
partir de cette place de la république
alors que l'ordre de dispersion a été
donnée par le préfet une manifestation
qui je rappelle n'avait pas été autorisé
pour cause de d'état d'urgence sanitaire
mais elle a été tolérée tant que cette
manifestation rester statique sur cette
place de la république
des jeunes qui ont la vue lève le poing
régulièrement c'est un signe contrôler
les contre le racisme qui a été importée
des états unis ce point levé qui dénonce
les violences policières notamment
américaines contre contre les afro
américains qui ont été victimes de ces
violences avec le dernier en date
georges floyd don qui est mort il est à
peu près 15 jours
la france et les défenseurs les
organisations de ces manifestations qui
font volontiers le parallèle avec ce qui
s'est passé aux états unis
une manifestation de ce type avait
d'ailleurs eu lieu le jour des obsèques
le jour où l'on rendait hommage à
georges floyd ce jour-là il y a eu un
rapport d'expertisé aussi qui
mettez en cause les policiers et qui
disait que adama traoré était mort par
par étranglement
je rappelle que dans cette enquête deux
personnes vont être auditionnés par les
policiers c'est ce qui a permis
d'ailleurs cette mobilisation
il s'agit d'un homme qui avait hébergé
adama traoré alors qu'il était en délit
de fuite cette personne avait averti les
policiers qui sont ensuite allés
l'interpeller
et puis une personne qui a visiblement
vu l'interpellation puisque je le
rappelle il n'y a aucune image de
l'interpellation d'adama traoré a à
l'époque des faits d'où cette affaire
qui dure maintenant depuis des années et
la vérité qui est compliqué à établir en
tout cas sur l'origine de la mort
d'adama traoré ça me rend tout cas vous
voyez a provoqué 2
une vive émotion et la colère en tout
cas de ces jeunes qui ont bravé
l'interdiction et sanitaires en tout cas
pour aller manifester
on va faire un point à présent avec
m'hamed kaki qui est en direct avec nous
bonsoir m'hamed kaki vous êtes président
de l'association les oranges
je sais pas si vous m'entendez voilà je
tenterais bien vous avez vu ces images
de manifestations il y avait quand même
pas mal de monde à peu près 5000
personnes selon le ministère de
l'intérieur
qu'en pensez vous est-ce que c'était le
bon moment pour manifester alors qu'on
est toujours je le rappelle en état
d'urgence sanitaire
alors écoutez j'ai été présent dans
cette manifestation de 13h à 17h c'est
une belle manifestation de toutes les
couleurs il avait des jeunes des lycéens
des anciens vraiment de toutes les
couleurs et c'était la joie et une un
seul mot d'ordre c'est le mot justice
ait donc jusqu'à 17 heures ça se passait
bien et à partir de 2007 leur envieront
la police a commencé à envoyer des gaz
et je pense que c'était pas opportun
d'une part et d'autre part
les rassemblements étaient encerclés de
toutes parts de la république que le
laissons pas la possibilité de marcher
puisque à l'origine de cette marche
c'était deux marchés visiblement et tous
les gens qui sont présents dans cette
manifestation sont écrites de justice de
paix est vraiment manger j'ai rencontré
des très belles personnes
c'est vraiment dommage et en nous ne
prenons pas ce que ce que le préfet
également à quoi ils jouent en envoyant
des gaz à des manifestants pacifiques et
le rappel de toutes les couleurs des
gugusses belle jeunesse qui sont là
pacifiquement mourant tout simplement
oui à la justice quand vous dites oui à
la justice c'est à dire puisqu'on sait
que l' enquête est toujours en cours
qu'il ya eu des expertises justice sera
faite quand quand la famille obtiendra
gain de cause
alors là il ya un vrai problème
nous entrons dans le coeur du problème
la vraie justice c'est quoi c'est la fin
de la hiérarchie des crédibilité comme
dirait le chercheur didier fassin vous
savez le problème c'est que il ya une
double peine à la fois il y a une il ya
des crimes policiers qu'on constate les
violences policières existe mais ce sont
maintenant des violences d'état c'est à
dire qu' un certain nombre de policiers
qui abusent de ce qu'on appelle la
violence légitime
1 la violence d'état mais il certains on
a un abuse et donc il y à des crimes
régulier on le froid dans plusieurs
affaires et dans la ferme de deux adama
traoré sont est une flagrante mais je
rappelle que sa date depuis des années
70 ces années 60
où il ya eu cependant de crimes qu y
compris dans les années 80 où un certain
nombre de gens ont été assassinés y
compris dans des commissariats comme à
sa part moi mais de diab qui est un
légendaire où il a été assassiné dans un
commissariat de police de versailles où
un officier de police lui a envoyé une
rafale de mitraillette à l'intérieur
même du commissariat
donc aujourd'hui les crimes un policier
ne ont été avérés depuis très très
longtemps il ya il y a une problématique
qui est systémique qui est systémique le
problème
ce que demande des citoyens et ce que
nous demandons tous je pense d'une
police dite républicaine c'est la
possibilité d'avoir un recours en
justice
or il y à une hiérarchie des crédits
bilité c'est à dire que la parole d'un
jeune de banlieue d'un jeune noir d'un
jeune arabe d'un jeune je dirais des
quartiers populaires tout simplement
même si les blancs c'est pas le problème
eh bien il n'a elle n'a pas de valeur
par rapport à un policier assermenté et
donc c'est la problématique et c'est là
qu'il faut changer de regard échangé
deux choses la deuxième chose importante
c'est les techniques de violences
policières qui amène à la mort et donc
dons qui sont largement contestée par
nombre d'experts etc et non convoi y
compris lorsque le ministre de
l'intérieur a tenté d'arrêter ces
techniques qui sont violentes et qui
sont meurtrières criminels qui à chaque
fois débouche sur la mort est bien en
interne vous avez elles vont être un
tarif ces techniques d'étranglement
m'hamed kaki
elles vont être interdits pour le moment
elles sont pas interdites il faut moi
j'attends le décret le le décret qui va
donner l'ordre
de ne plus les utiliser en il faut il
faut il faut que ça se soit socialiser
par parent fait administratif
donc tant que ce sera pas sorti en
attend le courrier de monsieur castaner
alençon des policiers pour leur
interdire cette cette possibilité
une possibilité qui amène à la mort
c'est parce que c'est ça qui est
vraiment laid matic quand vous quand
quelqu'un dit je ne peux plus respirer
je ne peux plus respirer et qu'on
continue à mettre le genou sur le coup
et bien c'est un assassinat en direct on
le voit bien on le voit dans le cadre de
la sphère adama traoré mais peladan
pleindoux tracé passait pas le seul cas
je répète que le cas de adama traoré est
symbolique de l'ensemble des crimes qui
se passe et on
je pense que les citoyens disent
aujourd'hui il y en a marre ça suffit on
remet pas en cause le fait qu'il y ait
de police
bien sûr la police allemande piéger les
gens elle moi c'est ce sont les gardiens
de la poule 1 et ils doivent garder leur
nom le gardien de la paix et non pas je
dirais se transformer en criminels par
des techniques qui ne sont qu ils ne
sont pas maîtrisés par une formation qui
est une formation à la serpette
aujourd'hui on sait très bien qu'un
certain nombre de policiers ne sont pas
du tout formés ils sont envoyés au casse
pipe comme ça est donc sacré sacré
effectivement des choses très graves sur
le terrain et ça c'est pas possible
et l'autre chose qui est vraiment
important c'est la possibilité de
recours quand il vous arrive quelque
chose est bien en tant que citoyen vous
qu'est ce que vous faites m'ont porté
plainte et ensuite normalement la
justice prend en charge cette
possibilité là aujourd'hui on voit bien
avec la police des polices l'igpn ne
fait ne n'est pas absolument pas
objective d'une part dans plein de cas
et d'autre part il ya une grave
possibilité de cette hiérarchie des
valeurs
hier archi des crédibilité comme dirait
didier fassin et cette hiérarchie était
crédité c'est à dire que entre entre
quelqu'un qui dit bah écoutez
n'importe l'épreuve japon voilà ce qu'on
m'a fait voilà ce qu'on a fait on va pas
le croire c'est à dire que le juge a
tendance à ne pas le croire et c'est ça
qu'il faut changer dans les mentalités
dans au niveau de la justice n'y a pas
qu'un problème de police il ya aussi un
problème de fonctionnement de la justice
et la proximité qu'il ya entre la police
et la justice sont problématiques
on va continuer d'en parler m'hamed kaki
rester avec nous et évidemment en direct
nous sommes également avec didier james
cofondateur de l'association hip hop est
une association indépendante des forces
de l'ordre pour la protection et la
prévention bonsoir didier j'aime ce vous
êtes avec nous en direct sur rt france
alors on a entendu un m'hamed kaki
parler de ces violences dirigées à
l'encontre des personnes issues des
quartiers défavorisés
parler du racisme aussi lui le qualifie
de systémique évidemment quel est votre
avis sur cette question
on a entendu issa traoré en début
d'après-midi condamné en tout cas la
mobilisation des forces de l'ordre hier
et et leur mobilisation justement contre
le fait d'interdire ces techniques
d'étranglement qu'en pensez vous écoutez
d'abord je remercie de m'avoir invité à
participer à ce débat
évidemment on va être forcément un petit
peu dans la controverse est ce que moi
j'ai un profil assez particulier dans la
mesure où je suis d'abord médecin
réanimateur urgentistes et où j'ai eu la
chance de participer pendant près de dix
ans au groupe medica de l'intervention
du raid qui est donc l'unité d'élite
antiterroriste que vous connaissez tous
- je suis actuellement donc président de
cette association le lit phoque est une
association totalement indépendante
et d'ailleurs je suis médecin je ne suis
pas policier elle a été créée avec des
collègues durèrent des collègues
policiers des collègues des forces de
sécurité intérieure est évidemment j'ai
un regard différent monsieur kaki
pourquoi nous avons créé cette
association parce que dans ce cocon très
particulier qui est finalement le
cabinet médical une unité de ce type
j'ai à ma grande surprise à cette époque
découvert l'univers de la police et
découvert des véritables drames sociaux
à l'opposé de ceux décrits monsieur
nakiele dans les forces de l'ordre
lorsqu'un de ses fonctionnaires et mis
en prison
c'est un drame qui se joue pour eux en
quelques heures ou leur
probité professionnelle leur probité
d'hommes est mise en cause pour des
faits qui sont heureusement la plupart
du temps des faits parfois très bénin ça
peut être tout simplement et c'est le
cas le plus fréquent des rapports qui
sont discutables
ça peut être effectivement des
allégations des altercations qui se
passe mal des échanges de coups qui
peuvent discuter mais très souvent fort
heureusement il ne s'agit pas de mise en
cause avec des blessures graves
même si depuis malheureusement
d'actualité mais rend de plus en plus
fréquent d'un constat il est parti de ça
il est parti d'un constat terrain il est
parti de ces témoignages et moi ce que
je veux dire que j'ai été témoin de deux
familles entières qui ont été détruites
par ces mises en accusation ce qui m'a
frappé dans ces dossiers c'est que c'est
l'instantanéité des choses il faut
comprendre comment ça se passe pour un
fonctionnaire de police qui est mise en
cause en quelques heures
il est convoqué par sa hiérarchie
directe parfois il est désarmé dans les
24 heures qui suivent
il est convoqué le plus souvent par
l'igpn
hélas parfois dans la foulée il se
retrouve devant un tribunal en référé et
il est mis en accusation
parfois même déferré parfois emprisonnés
donc c'est quelque chose qui va
extrêmement vite si je fais un parallèle
par exemple avec mon univers médical
c'est exactement et je les fais
d'ailleurs dans les commissions de
l'assemblée nationale où j'ai pu
témoigner
la commission présidée par monsieur
fauvergue justement pour essayer de
renforcer la sécurité
enfin la protection des forces de
l'ordre dans ce domaine social c'est
imaginer que moi en tant que médecin
samu ce que je fais régulièrement je me
retrouve à prendre en charge très
souvent sur la voie publique
un arrêt cardio respiratoire avec des
gestes techniques qui peuvent décider de
la vie évidemment de mutation que j'ai
sous la main
si je devais faire ce métier aujourd'hui
avec la pression médiatique que
subissent les forces de l'ordre dans la
rue avec cette diffusion quasi générale
de l'information vidéo à travers les
téléphones portables si je devais faire
ces gestes de réanimation avec la
famille par exemple du patient au dessus
des acquis beau film et si dans les
heures qui suivent je risquais de me
retrouver devant le directeur devant
l'hôpital puis le lendemain devant un
juge pour devoir répondre de mes actes
qui plus est face à des hommes qui ne
sont pas forcément désormais dollars qui
ne peuvent pas forcément en juger de la
pertinence de mes gestes
mais je pense finir ait plus aucun
médecin qui accepteraient ce jeu le
faire ce genre de jalal donc on a une
partie de ce principe à une fois qu'on
est parti d'un principe c'est qu'il
fallait absolument protéger et renforcer
la protection de ceux qui nous protège
parce que on aime justement ce qui
renforçait la protection de ceux qui
nous protègent ces policiers disent on a
besoin de cette technique de la n2 clé
d'étranglement pour interpeller des
individus récalcitrants est ce que cette
technique ou est susceptible de causer
des dommages et de quelle ampleur
alors oui là c'est le médecin qui va
vous parler bien sûr
et d'ailleurs on voit bien après moi je
veux pas trop rentrer dans la polémique
actuelle parce que je pense qu'elle est
par allen qui sont faits actuellement
entre les deux affaires qui occupent
l'actualité sont très très différentes
mais en l'occurrence je veux pas rentrer
dans les détails techniques et d'une
façon jusqu'au départ et bhl fronde des
deux affaires ce qui est sûr c'est que
oui bien sûr la date des tremblements a
potentiellement dangereuse par
définition en même temps nous on est
confronté aussi et là je reprendrai
le parallélisme avec l'univers médical
moi dans mon activité de réanimateurs on
est confronté à des forces vives ont été
confrontés régulièrement à des gens sous
l'emprise de drogues toxiques
on est confronté à des personnalités
psychiatrique extrêmement agressif et on
est confronté lui aussi à cette
problématique très fréquemment de devoir
maîtriser un individu en essayant des
évidemment le moins délétère possible et
c'est une véritable guerre
il faut savoir que par exemple un
individu ou psychiatrique forcené très
agressif
très souvent on a besoin de cinq
pompiers voir des forces de l'ordre qui
viennent en appui pour arriver à le
maîtriser suffisamment et et on est
obligé de lui donner une drogue s'est
bâti à travers le pantalon parce que
aussi et avec les plus grandes
précautions pour ne pas se blesser ou
même où quiconque n'a jamais été dans
cette situation je pense ne peut pas
prendre ndi savoir ce que ça représente
que 2 de devoir maîtriser quelqu'un qui
ne se laisse pas faire et c'est vrai
qu'il faut essayer de tout le moins
délétère possible là après ça ne relève
plus de videmment de mes prérogatives ni
de mes connaissances mais oui
probablement qu'il y a un vrai débat à
avoir là-dessus probablement je crois
que c'est le cas d'ailleurs il me semble
avoir lu un rapport de l'igpn en ce sens
avec par exemple l'utilisation du
pistolet à impulsions électriques qui
probablement peut être aussi une
solution mais attention aucune solution
n'est sans risque le pe peut très bien
aussi parfois de manière exceptionnelle
entraîné des dommages qui peuvent aller
jusqu'à la mort par arrêt cardiaque dans
certaines circonstances
donc je pense que ce débat actuel il
nécessite du recul nécessite d'être pris
à froid nécessite d'être pris dans
toutes ses composantes
mais en gardant bien à l'esprit que dans
l'immense majorité des cas ces
techniques sont utilisées par des gens
de façon professionnelle maîtrisé et
dans l'immense majorité des cas
n'aboutisse pas à ce que l'on décrit
actuellement dans dans la dans
l'actualité et nous à l'effort on
ne veux pas rentrer dans ce débat là moi
ce que je tiens absolument à dire
aujourd'hui c'est que mon engagement
dans cette association il est fait
autour de cette notion majeure pour nous
c'est que la police on en a besoin je
les ai côtoyés pendant dix ans je suis
médecin je ne suis pas policier
j'ai appris à les amener à les apprécier
dans l'immense majorité des cas ce sont
des héros qui nous protège et qui pour
quelques milliers d'euros sont là anne
est quotidiennement leur vie en cause et
au péril de leur propre vie
ils sont dans la rue et c'est une
situation qui est extrêmement
angoissante et qui peuvent sans
l'excuser parfois expliquer certains
dérapages new eyes for on dit une seule
chose on dit qu'il n'ya pas de raison
pour que les forces de l'ordre et a une
position particulière face à la loi qui
serait que la présomption d'innocence
qui est effectivement une règle dans
notre justice pour les forces de l'ordre
malheureusement la réalité de terrain
c'est qu'elles se transforment souvent
en une présomption de culpabilité
est ce que l'on fait l'effort uniquement
et on prend pas parti pour personne ont
rétabli pour les forces de l'ordre la
possibilité à travers un produit qui est
un produit d'assurance spécifiquement
fait pour eux parlent pour eux qui va
permettre dans ses premières heures de
leur apporter l'assistance juridique
financière
les gardes d'enfants dont les maîtres en
considération de pouvoir se défendre on
va on reste avec vous
didier jammes vous restez avec nous en
direct sur rt france on voit ces images
de la place de la république où les
jeunes
manifestants sont toujours présents
l'ordre d'évacuation a été donné mais on
le voit il reste sur place pour
l'instant les tensions sont quelque peu
retombées mettre les pièces que vous
comprenez ce que didier jamet aussi
c'est compliqué quand on est policier
aussi de gérer au quotidien les
violences ils en sont eux mêmes et
victimes vous êtes d'accord
- g j'entends bien que c'est un métier
qui est pas facile quand tous les
métiers mais justement parce que c'est
un métier pas facile c'est qu'il faut
que chacun respecte la déontologie
or ce dont on parle là précisément il ya
la problématique des techniques
violentes qui conduisent à la mort ça je
pense que c'est pas la peine de
s'attarder dessus d'autant plus que le
ministre de l'intérieur s'est engagé à
les retirer les interdire donc ça c'est
plutôt une bonne nouvelle et j'espère
qu'il ira jusqu'au bout de sa et qui
doit donc si les statuts qui
représenterait des personnages de
l'histoire qui qui auraient cautionné
l'esclavagé ou autres ségrégation alors
non alors ça c'est l'essentiel voire une
problématique
moi je parle des techniques de des
techniques de deux morts la technique de
l'étouffement du jeu luis herrera qui
lors d'une interpellation peut
assassiner des individus ça c'est
quelque chose d'important qui pourrit de
fuller il faut il faut là il faut
vraiment retirer ces techniques l'a22
des mains des policiers parce qu'elles
conduisent à la mort la deuxième chose
c'est pas parler est ce donc c'est
l'objet parce que georges floyd qui a
été assassiné ou aux états unis
ce qu'on a pu voir c'est un racisme
systémique c'est que
aujourd'hui et ça date pas seulement
d'aujourd'hui je voulais dit tout à
l'heure avec mohamed dia en 1972 lorsque
l'officier dans le commissariat de
police de versailles lui a envoyé une
rafale systémique en france également si
je vous suis bien c'est bien ça une
somme systémique c'est à dire qu'on
laisse faire un certain racisme
d'ailleurs une fois gérante de ma
famille pas plus tard que hier qui se
fait interpeller il se fait tutoyer
vous voyez ça commence par des petites
choses qui énervent c'est à dire que et
et si vous voulez l'escaladent elle part
tout de suite c'est à dire que au nom de
quoi un policier qui arrête quelqu'un va
le tutoyer et le problème c'est qu'ils
le tutoie dans certain nombre de
quartiers populaires mais il va pas te
tutoyer dans le 16e arrondissement à
versailles on désignait voyez c'est ça
la justice c'est ça le fait que les deux
poids deux mesures à saint germain en
laye rumba et toc
on va être plus poli on va on va vous
voyez les gens que c'était rare on va
les respecter et et le problème de la
jeunesse qu'est ce qui le demande de
mandat de la question d'être respecté
ainsi des policiers veulent être
respectés
il faut qu'il respecte lors des
interpellations les gens avec des
conduites de déontologie les gens me
collard oui pardon de m'hamed kaki vous
restez avec nous on va faire un point
sur ce qui se passe place de la
république à présent va rejoindre notre
reporter thomas bonne et on continue ce
débat entre vous didier jamais et il m'a
m cac et thomas bonnet vous êtes place
de la république
voile et les tensions sont quelque peu
retombées qu'on est il actuellement
les tensions sont retombées en fait ce
qui a calmé les choses c'est
l'intervention des organisateurs de la
famille notamment
adama traoré qui ont appelé au calme ils
ont dû arrêter de jeter des projectiles
ils ont demandé aux manifestants de ne
redoute pas attaqué la police de ne pas
se focaliser sur la police est depuis ce
moment-là les chaussons la merci
monsieur
depuis ce moment là les on reprend vous
reprendre à thomas évidemment tout à
l'heure pour faire un point donc les
tensions qui sont retombés place de la
république des manifestants qui
apparemment ont entendu l'appel de la
famille de 10 à traoré de ne pas jeter
des projectiles en direction des forces
de l'ordre on le voit donc cette ce
comité qui veut l'apaisement et ne pas
envenimer les choses déjà que la
situation est assez tendue des deux
côtés didier jamet 7 cette mobilisation
dénonce aussi le racisme dans la police
on parlait des violences avec vous mais
est ce que vous sentez de votre côté
vous bd des agents qui sont racistes
écoutez on n'est pas dans le monde des
bisounours je vais rejoindre monsieur
kaki et je vais très très transparent
bien sûr je pense qu'il y a des gens à 6
dans la police comme il y en a dans
l'absolu mans tous les corps de métiers
y compris parmi certains de mes
collègues médecins mais ce que je peux
vous dire moi et je pense que c'est ça
le plus important c'est que j'ai passé
dix ans un du raid
bon vous les connaissez avec les
cagoules noires mais moi j'ai eu la
chance de les fréquenter dans la vie de
tous les jours visage découvert je suis
tu être créés trial
j'avais des collègues de toutes les
couleurs dans ce groupe et nous étions
unis autour de quoi de valeurs communes
qui n'avait strictement rien à voir avec
aucune autre interprétation et qui ne
laissait pas la capacité à
interprétation on était là pour défendre
voilà des valeurs fortes des valeurs de
patriotisme comme tout concitoyens doit
en avoir et c'est est partagée aussi
bien par des sujets de toutes les
religions qui étaient présentes dans ce
grand jeu j'avoue que je ne comprends
pas ce débat je ne dis pas qu'il n'ya
pas de racisme dans la police mais je
dis que ça n'est pas ce n'est pas le
problème aujourd'hui là où je rejoins
monsieur k qui c'est qu'effectivement ce
qui paraît plus important que tout le
reste c'est qu'il y ait un respect
mutuel c'est à dire que le jeu dans un
monde idéal il faudrait le public et
l'ensemble du public et bien respecte sa
police et effectivement et la tue je le
rejoins j'ai constaté certains dérapages
qu'à titre personnel je
je peux ne pas approuver il faut
également que les forces de police fasse
preuve du plus grand professionnalisme
possible mais là où je vais tempéré les
propos monsieur calvi c'est que j'ai eu
la chance de vivre des situations
d'arrestation extrêmement difficile qui
n'étaient pas toujours liés à du lac de
grand banditisme de l'acte de vente est
rythmée par exemple dans les cités et en
particulier de certaines cités de la
région parisienne
je peux vous certifier que malgré tout
notre équipement malgré tout nos
entraînements et malgré toute notre
expérience j'ai vécu des situations ma
vie et je sentais que ma vie sain deux
de mes collègues étaient potentiellement
en danger
et cette sensation de danger il faut le
comprendre aussi
elle est humaine ne peut entraîner des
réactions elle aussi humaine parfois
dérapent c'est pour ça que iphone on ne
veux pas trop rentrer dans ce débat là
on est là pourquoi on est là vraiment
pour dire oui il ya des situations qui
peuvent déraper
oui il peut y avoir des policiers qui ne
respectent pas le code de déontologie
mais ce que l'on ne veut pas qu'on
n'accepte pas et fort c'est que la
présomption d'innocence soit bafouée en
quelques heures
nous ce que l'on leur tonnes comme droit
et on estime que c'est un droit
fondamental qui va permettre de régler
d'ailleurs toute dissension qui va
retirer une épine du pied de
l'administration qui l'a bien compris
c'est finalement il n'est pas là pour
juger avant tout le monde on est là pour
blesser aux fonctionnaires aux collègues
la possibilité de se défendre ce qu'il
est mis en cause il importe qui peut
être nous ont suffisamment dans son
activité professionnelle et bien et
légumes en cause
on lui donne la possibilité de se
défendre et ensuite on laisse et nous on
a confiance dans la justice
on laisse la justice faire son travail
in fine et si la justice estime qu'il ya
une faute qui a une erreur qui a été
commise
il sera plus
mais il aura au moins le moyen se
défendent comme n'importe quel citoyen
finalement qui est mise en pause à dans
les 24 heures payées par la société un
avocat et un médecin en garde à vue pour
l'assister ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui pour la police la protection
fonctionnelle qui lui est accordée j'ai
peut-être vous connaissez et bien c'est
en fait une protection qui est très
souvent refusée il faut savoir que l est
très compliquée à obtenir il faut savoir
que lorsqu'un collègue est mis en cause
et bien l'administration a deux mois
pour lui répondre et que le silence son
refus donc imaginé en deux mois la vie
c'est déjà écroulé pour lui et il est
pour l'heure mis en cause vraiment
profondément touchée en son être propre
et qu'ils évitent comprend des bons
temps on a bien compris que c'était
compliqué des deux côtés dans des
situations souvent conflictuelles tout
n'est pas tout noir ou tout blanc
pardonnez moi cette formule mais on le
voit les difficultés en tout cas du
maintien de l'ordre
existe des deux côtés merci beaucoup
didier jammes d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur rt france en direct
une dernière question pour vous m'hamed
kaki on le comprend que ces situations
de maintien de leurs peuvent peuvent
amener à des drames
vous vous dites qu'il y à du racisme
systémique dans la police qu'en est-il
de 2,2 de ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui ce
qui est importé des états unis vous dit
finalement on vit la même situation en
france et on en est au point je réitère
ma question à remettre en cause des
statuts des des films qu'en pensez vous
écoutez il y a des le problème se situe
plutôt l inverse c'est à dire que
l'histoire coloniale n'est pas enseignée
d'une part rien eu le nez dans l'espace
public qui est un montre cette histoire
coloniale que nous avons en france et
qui alors qu'aux états unis vous avez vu
qu'il y avait des déboulonnage de statut
qui était l'exemple même de d'une
histoire de l' esclavage des
esclavagistes d'une espèce de
provocation permanente mais qui ne met
pas un qui ne permet pas en avant
l'histoire de l'esclavagé donc pourquoi
que je comprends que l'émotion amenés à
les déboulonner pour dire eh bien c'est
un geste symbolique très fort pour dire
ça suffit d' esclavage
cette histoire là on n'en veut pas et
bien en france je dirais c'est l'absence
totale de l'histoire coloniale dans
l'espace public et est donc ça c'est un
instant vrai problème par exemple
moi j'ai milité pendant plus de vingt
ans pour
denis avec des amis avec notre collectif
le boulevard du 17 octobre 1961 et donc
il est acquis je au cou priorité au
direct
on retourne place de la république pour
faire un point avec notre reporter et
c'était le far gestel qu'en est il
actuellement on voit des gaz
lacrymogènes qui fusent
1 place de la république
oui exactement magali à l'ambiance était
calme et 1 depuis grosse minute et et
puis là il y a eu
des gaz lacrymogènes qui ont fusé vous
l'avais dit la place de la république
difficile de vous dire pourquoi est ce
qui s'est passé précisément puisque nous
sommes au niveau de la rue du faubourg
du temple est allé gaz lacrymogènes
provenaient 2 est la rue de turbigo
détention la tension semble maintenant à
retomber
il y à vous allez pouvoir le voir sur
ces images de julien de la cour le cas
des organisateurs qui est positionnée au
niveau de la place de la république les
organisateurs qui sont en train de
s'adresser aux manifestants
le plus gros des manifestants a
maintenant et maintenant partie de cette
place de la république je vous le
rappelle qu'il y a environ 45 minutes à
la préfecture de police a demandé aux
manifestants de quitter les lieux ils
ont il a appelé la préfecture a appelé
les manifestants à se disperser en
raison à des tensions à qui on est
émerger dans cette manifestation
vous le voyez sur ces images de à julien
de la cour le calme qui semble être
revenue ici la place de la république et
on le voit merci est allé on voit
effectivement sur ces images en direct
les crs et les gendarmes mobiles qui se
sont positionnés sur les artères qui
mènent à cette place de la république
visiblement pour procéder à
à la dispersion de cette mobilisation
qui s'est tenue une mobilisation
statique aujourd'hui qu'ils n'avaient
pas été autorisées mais tolérée à
condition justement qu'elle reste sur
cette place de la république à cause des
contraintes sanitaires et on le voit
toujours ces manifestants en colère qui
manifestent pour la justice et qui sont
un peu échaudé évidemment par ces gaz
lacrymogène qui sont tirés alors que la
manifestation d'esprit 6o déroulait
plutôt dans le calme des manifestants
qui certains manifestants qui ont décidé
de rester et de ne pas rentrer chez eux
didier jamais vous parler de la détresse
des policiers on le sait ils sont sûrs
sollicité actuellement
est-ce que cette sur-sollicitation peut
engendrer des comportements de stress
telles que ça peut mener à des dérives
oui la ccl médecin qui vous parle
de fait la double casquette d'aix d'ex
membres de la police
oui bien sûr de toute façon toutes les
situations de stress peuvent en jambes
et gestes - contrôler voire un contrôle
et c'est bien pour ça que ce que je vous
disais tout à l'heure c'est je pense que
ce qui pour bien comprendre avec le
grand public comprenne c'est que si je
fais par exemple parallèle avec une
erreur médicale tandis qu'à voir info
que cadel existe on a la même
problématique
mais moi par exemple dans mon exercice
de médecins si je suis soupçonné d'une
erreur
avoir des mois pour préparer ma défense
pour pouvoir analyser ce qui s'est passé
un policier lui c'est pas possible il
est mis en accusation dans les 24 à 48
heures ça va extrêmement vite donc c'est
vraiment pour ça qu'on s'est rendu
compte qu'il fallait l'assister dans ces
moments là le problème a dit qu'elle est
vraiment très différentes
on fait tous les deux des métiers ce
soir les policiers nationale on va
écouter à issa traoré qui est en train
de parler justement place de la
république
[Applaudissements]
et continue je prends 18 juillet à pau
ce mois çi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les européens désolé je ne pense pas une
information n'était pas juste
[Applaudissements]
la police et les secours un bonus
passifs et la chaussée
[Applaudissements]
l'opération de assa traoré la demi soeur
de la victime qui est mort par
étouffement a priori en 2016 lors de son
interpellation le jeune adama avait
avait un peu plus de 20 ans à l'époque
des faits m'hamed kaki une question sont
quand même des paroles assez virulentes
de la part de sa demi-soeur police
fasciste la fachosphère vous pensez pas
que cette généralisation est un petit
peu démesuré si je puis dire je pense
pas qu elles généralisent mois qu'elle a
elle a eu au contraire un discours tout
à fait à présent depuis le début en
disant qu' il fallait que les policiers
qui au web et anthologies qu'ils
respectent les lois républicaines ne
puisse dénoncer ceux qui le qui font des
débordements grave et raciste et elle a
dit à chaque fois qui a effectivement il
n'ya qu'une france c'est pas la majorité
mais il ya une frange importante de gens
qui ne respectent rien dans la police et
qui clique et afellay mélanie les
plagistes et airs et on le sert il ya
des groupuscules qui donne envie mais
les choses et on a vu cette vidéo d'un
policier noir se faire insulter par part
de manifestants
excusez moi et parce que j'étais dans
cette manifestation de 13 heures
moi je sais ce que j'ai vu c'est des
gens extrêmement pacifique et c'est je
pense la responsabilité du préfet
l'allemand de mal géré cette affaire là
parce que pourquoi il on doit des gaz
pour des gens qui sombre debout assis
tranquillement en train d'écouter un
certain nombre de discours
il n'y a pas eu aucun le problème dans
cette danse est un assemblement à la
république et nous avons été gazés à un
moment donné je ne comprends pas je ne
comprends pas si ce n'est de la
convocation ou alors est ce qu'on attend
est ce que les choses semblent
am donc vous voyez la responsabilité des
aussi politique et administrative le
préfet l'allemand eon la rue il s'est
illustré à plusieurs reprises dans sa
gestion une traque de gestion il était
d'ailleurs rappelé à l'ordre à plusieurs
reprises mais visiblement c'est top je
vois que il n'a plus sa place dans la
gestion de ce type de moi ce qu'il sait
pas faire il sait pas faire il ya eu
d'autres gens qui ont une manifestation
comme celle-ci elle est tout à fait
gérable robot wars ont lancé des gaz
lacrymogènes à des gens qui sont
pacifiques
il c'est comme ça qu'on met la rage au
coeur aux gens c'est quand on n'a rien
fait et consulté casey et jongler j'en
suis témoin et on le voit beaucoup de
jeunes effectivement dans cette
manifestation vous étiez m'hamed kaki
c'était s'éteint une cause si je peux
dire qui et qui immobilise beaucoup la
jeunesse sauver la jeunesse aujourd'hui
aspire tous il ya des identifications
collective à la paix et à la justice
et le fait d'être traitées chaque
élément qu'ils soient traités de la même
manière qu'ils soient lac blanc jaune
vert rouge noir
ce qu'on veut c'est ça qu'on veut de la
jeunesse soit depuis ce depuis tout
l'après midi j'ai entendu le mot justice
justice et surtout le fait qu' on soit
traité de la même manière et surtout qu'
il y ait une crédibilité des propos des
uns et des autres je veux dire que l'or
quand on est face à une justice face à
un policier et vient que
l'administration de la crau mais
aujourd'hui elle est apportée par plein
de vidéos on le voit venir à l'histoire
des [ __ ] par exemple à
l'ile-saint-denis vous avez lu ces
policiers qui ont prêté cet homme qui
était dans la scène de biko qu'il
fallait écoulée mais c'est très grave ça
c'est ça qu'il fout la rage au coeur de
la geneste et c'est ça qui fait qu'on
que les jeunes ne peuvent plus croire en
cette police
malheureusement et je pense qu'il faut
changer complètement nos méthodes et je
pense que ça c'est le ministre castaner
mais aussi du préfet aujourd'hui le
préfet l'allemand vraiment c'est plus le
catastrophe sa gestion est
catastrophique et je pense qu'ils
permettent au mur
cet homme alors on est en fin de
manifestation il est 18 heures 42 place
de la république on voit certains
manifestants qui ont décidé de ne pas
écouter en tout cas cet ordre de
dispersion ils sont toujours sur place
il ya toujours des discours qui se font
pour ce que vous disiez m'hamed kaki
réclamer justice
didier jammes la police aujourd'hui on
le sait hier elle à manifester parce que
cette généralisation pour elle est
injuste elle dit qu'elle n'est pas
raciste qui l'y a peut-être des éléments
perturbateurs comme partout dans la
société française finalement vous
comprenez leur désarroi ils se disent
lâché par christophe castaner ils ont
besoin d'être soutenus davantage selon
vous oui bien sûr c'est une évidence
j'entends bien les propos de ce cas qui
je suis
by je pense moi le sujet évidemment je
l'abordé un éclairage totalement
différent j'ai vécu dix ans avec des
gens qui étaient obnubilés par la devise
du service qui était servir sans faillir
moi j'ai vu des gens exceptionnels
j'ai vu alors effectivement
unité d'élite mais j'ai rencontré
beaucoup de gens dans ma positionner
j'ai rencontré beaucoup d'instructeurs
j'ai visité des écoles de police j'ai
participé avec il faut qu'on tient
énormément à ça aussi avoir une action
de prévention à travers des séminaires à
travers les textes des retours
d'expérience sur ce que on a pu vivre
mais moi j'ai une autre vision forcément
j'ai une vision d'homme qui pour un
salaire fait bien fièrement risquent
leur vie tous les jours avec toujours
évidemment cette notion bien présente
dans leur tête de possibilités d'erreurs
avec une pression très importante avec
un stress majeur dans des circonstances
très difficiles et qui garde un
professionnalisme comme pour moi
j'estime exemplaire et je n'ai pas
d'exemple que j'ai vécu évidemment dans
les limites de ma fonction de médecin
j'ai une vision inverse il ce qui est
souvent pape a soutenu parce qu'il
manque d'aidé des bras il manque des
moyens dans leur mission notamment cette
police de proximité qui a disparu et qui
étaient en lien direct avec certaines
personnes dans les quartiers ses surnoms
de moyens aussi qui crée ce type de
situation selon vous ils leur montrent
beaucoup de choses
il leur manque clairement beaucoup de
choses et nous évidemment on leur
apporte dans ses situations de mise en
cause qu'on a estimé le plus urgent le
plus prioritaire qui devrait être une
évidence on devrait même pas avoir à en
parler et il devrait je ne comprends pas
encore qui est finalement un policier
qui acceptent de faire du maintien de
l'ordre dans la rue sans avoir ce
produit d'assurance multirisques voilà
c'est comme si moi je faisais ma
profession de médecin sans avoir
une assurance professionnelle qui me
couvre en cas de pépin on fait des
métiers beaucoup trop difficile beaucoup
trop parisse pour ne pas pouvoir se
doter d'un outil capable de nous donner
les moyens de se défendre encore une
fois il s'agit pas de juger maintenant
les moyens bien sûr qu'il en manque mais
ce qui je pense est aujourd'hui le plus
important c'est qu'ils se sentent
soutenus par leur hiérarchie
parce que la police donc on en a besoin
et encore une fois moi je j'ai une
vision 2 effectivement assez admiratif
comme d'ailleurs pour avoir une vision
assez admiratif de notre métier de
médecin
finalement le parallélisme est assez
fort entre les deux professions
on a tous les thèmes évoqués également
qui est parfois d'être aperçus qu'ils
les prennent aux siennes et qu'on est en
débat là on est dans des métiers et je
dirais qu'ils sont dans les fondements
de notre société
je ne pense pas qu'aujourd'hui on puisse
concevoir une société moderne sans une
police efficace la plus respectueuse
possible sans des médecins les plus
efficaces possibles de la crise
sanitaire coville a bien montré elle a
remis en valeur toute la nécessité
d'avoir un système de santé publique
efficace et évidemment les pompiers et
d'autres
qu'est ce que parce qu'une société une
ville sans pompiers l'histoire est
pleine de
qui se sont embrasées donc on est dans
des métiers absolument institutionnels
je pense malgré tout même en étant très
vigilant et là je rejoins le monsieur
qui a acquis sur d'éventuels dérapages
et il faut les condamner
il faut les punir mais il ya un autre
métier qui est fondateur c'est la
justice
elle est là pour que ça la justice la
problématique aujourd'hui on ne voit
bien et vous êtes bien sûr partie
prenante les médias là dedans c'est que
finalement ce qui est nouveau ce qui est
nouveau c'est que chacun a dans sa poche
un téléphone portable une vidéo qui va
permettre finalement de diffuser manière
quasi instantanée et de manière virale
des informations mais ces informations
suite il faut les traiter ils font les
décanter avec du recul et il faut le
faire avec le recul nécessaire que la
justice dans ces métiers finalement on
leur redonne à la justice sa position et
on permet aux fonctionnaires de police
de se défendre tout simplement merci
beaucoup que tout le monde des deux
côtés d'ailleurs puissent se défendre
merci beaucoup monsieur jeanne d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur arte france
c'est la fin de cette édition spéciale
merci beaucoup
m'hamed kaki également pour votre
analyse est d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur rt france on va rejoindre
tout de suite notre reporter estelle
farges place de la république pour faire
un dernier point de la situation mais
visiblement estelle allait les
manifestants sont en train pour certains
en tout cas de quitter cette place de la
république les policiers re sont là pour
faire respecter l'ordre d'évacuation
mais exactement magali à ce qui se passe
c'est que maintenant toujours le gros
des manifestants s'est rassemblée à vous
allez pouvoir le voir sur ces images de
geignards de la cour au niveau de la rue
du faubourg du temple avec les karaté
organisateurs et qui sont à présent
qu'ils sont présents pour leur adresser
ce qui ressemble à un dernier mot ces
manifestants ils sont en train de se
disperser dans le calme ils ont je vous
le rappelle un répondu à l'appel du
collectif adama traoré des manifestants
et qui sont venus à dénoncer le racisme
et les violences policières au sein des
forces de l'ordre une manifestation qui
s'est globalement déroulée dans le calme
malgré quelques tensions entre les
manifestants et les forces de l'ordre en
fin de journée je vous rappelle que le
cortège était censé rejoindre la place
de l'opéra même la préfecture de police
a finalement a décidé que le
rassemblement resterez est statique la
préfecture de police qu'il ya un fou qui
a appelé il ya un peu plus d'une heure
les manifestants à se disperser en
raison donc des tensions qui ont émergé
au cours de la journée
merci beaucoup estelle pour toutes ces
précisions estelle farges en direct de
la place de la république à paris où
vous le voyez la manifestation contre le
racisme et contre les violences
policières organisé à l'initiative
notamment du comité adama traoré est en
train est en cours d'évacuation par les
forces de l'ordre une manifestation qui
a commencé en début d'après midi qui
s'est déroulée dans le calme tout au
long de cette journée et on voit
quelques tensions à la dispersion somme
toute assez classique pas de pas de
dégradation peler les manifestants qui
vont en ce moment
rentré en tout cas la police va faire
respecter cet ordre d'évacuation on va
faire un point dans 10minutes rester
avec nous c'est la fin de cette édition
spéciale et on se retrouve pour un point
complet de cette manifestation et sur
l'actualité dans une dizaine de minutes
pour le journal de 19h heure de paris
restez avec nous
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coût politique a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité d idée courageuse des
mots qui comptent en soi vient de
l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on ne bouge plus